That's just how life is
on Earth 2.0
Double the density,
This is 'What If,'
and here's what would happen
if Earth's gravity were to double.
See how the Earth
moves around the Sun?
Its current elliptical path
gives us winter and summer,
without bringing us
too close to our star.
Since the Sun is 330,000 times
heavier than Earth,
its gravitational influence
pulls the Earth towards it.
Luckily, our planet moves
sideways from the Sun's pull,
and fast enough,
so that it doesn't get sucked
into that giant ball of hot plasma.
But up the gravity on Earth by just
a little bit, and you ruin everything.
If Earth's gravity was just 5% stronger,
the increase would warp our planet's
near-perfect circlular orbit
into a tighter elliptical path.
Summers and winters would
become a lot harsher,
the intense climate change
would spark widespread famine
and would likely collapse
the world economy.
And yet, there might
be some survivors.
That's just from a 5% difference.
Let's put climate concerns
aside for a moment.
Realistically, we just wouldn't
survive a drastic change.
The Earth's core would probably
just collapse in on itself,
causing everyone to
fall to their deaths,
or releasing enough heat
to cook us all alive!
But let's imagine that gravity doubles
at a rate that allows us to keep our lives,
so we can try this new world out.
Well, to be honest, there
isn't much to look forward to.
You're now twice as heavy.
And while that might sound
like a gift to some of you,
it won't be unless
you're in great shape...
Your heart and lungs will be
strained under the increased pressure.
Breathing gets harder, and
your blood pressure skyrockets.
Imagine, you're basically giving
yourself a piggyback ride 24/7.
Sleeping gives you bed sores, stairs get scary,
and trips and falls might even become fatal!
Speaking of falls, our infrastructure,
our technology, and nature itself,
aren't equipped to handle
this type of force.
Buckling under twice the
weight they were built for,
buildings and bridges would collapse;
planes would also fall from the sky;
and satellites would
tumble back to Earth;
since they’d no longer be traveling
at the right orbital velocity.
Trees would collapse
under their own weight,
or they would die from not being able
to pump water as high as they used to.
New ones growing in their place
would be much shorter and thicker
in order to accomodate the
new constraints of double gravity.
And like that, perhaps humans
would evolve the same way:
decreased height, thicker veins,
increased bone density.
Barring the severe climate change
that would occur,
such as atmospheric compression
and increased radioactivity,
we might actually be able to
build a nice little life for ourselves.
That is, one where everything is
smaller and a closer to the ground,
but what's wrong with that anyway?
Double gravity or not, life is short!
So try something new,
let your mind wander,
and circle back for more 'What If.'